طالب متظاهرون في شوارع العاصمه الفرنسيه
باريس بوقف فوري ودائم لاطلاق النار في
قطاع غزه وتمكين الشعب الفلسطيني من اقامه
دولته على ارضه وردد المتظاهرون شعارات
تتهم الغرب بما وصفوه بالتواطئ في ارتكاب
جرائم حرب وتطهير عرقي في حق ابناء غزه
واخرى تطالب بحمايه المدنيين والطواقم
الطبيه وطواقم الاغاثه والصحفيين الذين لم
يستثنوا من الاستهداف كما حذر المشاركون
من نذر نكبه جديده للشعب الفلسطيني في ظل
استمرار سياسه الفصل العنصري والافلات من
المحاسبه التي او الذي تتمتع به
اسرائيل نظم الائتلاف الفلسطيني بولايه
شمال الراين الالمانيه وحركه الجيل
العالمي مسيره بمدينه دسلدورف تنديدا
بالعدوان الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه وما
وصفوه بسياسه القتل الممنهج ضد المدنيين
في ربوع القطاع وطالب المحتجون بوقف فوري
لاطلاق
النار